all right it's 9 45 uh so we will uh I
will open up this public hearing uh for
the house election law committee we'll
start with the pledge real fast
representative bone you want to lead us
up
okay
all right excellent
um I'm going to open the public hearing
for cacr uh nine
um relative to the New Hampshire
presidential primary providing that the
New Hampshire primary will be the first
president of primary of a presidential
election cycle I believe um Grant vosse
from the Senate is here to introduce the
bill Mr bossy welcome to election law
good morning chairman Berry members of
the election law committee it's good to
be back my name is Grant bosse from the
New Hampshire Senate introducing cacr9
on behalf of Senator Darrell Abbas it's
Prime sponsor a little history not
necessarily for the committee but for
anybody watching uh it was first held in
1916 to select delegates to the
Republican and Democratic national
conventions in 1952 the first primary
were voters directly voted for
presidential candidates Dwight
Eisenhower upset Robert Taft since 1975
state law mandates that New Hampshire's
primary be held at least a week before
any similar contest and the legislature
entrusted the secretary of state with
authority to move that date to make sure
we stay first in the nation why is it
important not just for New Hampshire and
our tourist industry and our and our
vanity and our pride why is it important
for the nation New Hampshire voters
expect candidates to earn their votes
Grassroots campaigns Force candidates to
persuade voters making them better
candidates and better prepared to serve
as president
winning in New Hampshire or having a
surprisingly good showing can help
candidates secure their party's
nomination a poor showing in New
Hampshire can end a struggling campaign
narrowing the field for the upcoming
contests
protecting the first in the nation
primary is important the current
challenge to our primary is not from
other states Delaware or Arizona or
Nevada as it has been in the past but
from Washington D.C
while the Republican National Committee
has confirmed New Hampshire's status the
Democratic National Committee wants us
to move other states in front of us and
threatens to not seat New Hampshire
delegates if we indeed stay first in
line with state law in fact
last year the DNC sent this legislature
a list of changes to our state election
laws just to be considered for the third
or fourth plot in their calendar
cacr9 would give New Hampshire voters
the chance to cement our state's first
in the nation primary into the state
constitution this is more than merely
symbolic it would also protect the
primary from future demands that the
legislature abandoned first in the
nation Senator Abbas thanks you for your
consideration and your support of cacr9
and hopes you will send it to the voters
in the fall thank you thank you
um are there any questions from the
committee
all right because I've always wanted to
do this to you grant I'm going to gavel
you down
just so we can have a good laugh about
it later all right with that uh there's
anyone else wishing to speak to cacr9
I'm seeing none representative wood can
you bring me the blue sheet
three minutes
and he was gaveled down I wanted that in
the notes he was gaveled down uh no one
uh no one signed up to speak either to
sign up for against it um with that I
will close the public hearing for cacr9
and end this public hearing for the
house election law committee and I will
see you all in 10 minutes for the
subcommittee thank you very much
thank you
thank you all for being here at the
second meeting of the house election law
subcommittee on campaign finance and
please join me in reciting the Pledge of
Allegiance as we begin the meeting
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
well thank you again all for being here
uh the purpose of this subcommittee is
to uh
take a look at campaign Financial R in
the state of New Hampshire and
see if the interested parties here on
the subcommittee
can find some areas we agree could stand
some improvement
and I see that our secretary of state
Scanlon is here
and thank you for coming and we would be
interested in hearing uh
What legislation you think would be
helpful to the Secretary of State's
office uh would be helpful in making
improvements from your end and also what
improvements you have in mind and what
your priorities are so if you'd care to
speak with us
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State and with me is Bud Fitch legal
counsel to the office and hopefully all
of you know bud uh if you don't then I'd
suggest you get to know him because he
he really knows the election laws better
than almost anybody else in the state of
New Hampshire
um
hopefully including campaign Finance
laws
the position of our office on campaign
Finance generally has been that it's the
realm of the legislature to determine
the campaign Finance policy
and uh and and processes and we
administer uh
the laws that the legislature passes
um
with that said I think over time the
campaign Finance laws have become
incredibly confusing
and complicated to the point that even
staff in my office have a difficult time
you know explaining how the law Works to
uh uh candidates and political
committees
what I would like to see
and I am more than happy to help with
this effort personally you know through
the summer so that a bill could be
sponsored next year is to just
consolidate the different types of
political committees
streamline the statute as much as we can
have simple
uh
contribution requirements
and you know the whole idea with
campaign Finance is transparency and
disclosure
and it doesn't have to be that
complicated we just you know if we if we
just have a one-size-fits all
approach that we can keep really simple
I think that's to the benefit
not only the people have to file these
reports
but also the people that want to view
them you know and understand how
campaigns are financed
and where the money is going
will benefit everyone
so I that's the thirty thousand foot
level of what I think the direction that
I think we should go I will say that at
the moment we are currently getting
ready to replace the campaign Finance uh
online filing system so this discussion
is Timely
we have already invited the political
parties to provide input uh into what
the new system should look like but I
think this exercise is a really
important part of that
um I'm going to turn this over to Bud
now because he has done a lot of the
work on the uh
on the details the detail part of the
statute send he'll have have some more
specific
comments and suggestions so Bud thank
you very much thank you committee I have
a handout for you if I can approach and
provide them with it you go to the mic
thank you
you go home Jerry
so there are is a lot of information in
the document that I've just handed out
it's intended to identify areas of the
campaign Finance law that we have
struggled with or we think it's so
complex that it might benefit from being
simplified
um I'll proceed in any way you want to
um unless you direct something else I'll
just do a quick 30 000 foot overview of
this but not go into all the detail and
if you see an area that is of interest
to you you can read the further detail
there and I'm happy to take questions at
any moment in time is that okay Mr
chairman that's fine that's good thank
you
so the first issue secretary Scanlan
referred to is
there are nine different types of
registration if you parse the statute
and I've laid out in as much detail as I
can what they probably are
in many cases while there are Provisions
in the statute that create each of the
nine
and we try to construe them in a way
that makes each mutually exclusive of
the other I can tell you our experiences
that many of the people that use the
system people that file see the list of
nine more as a a menu choice where they
get to pick and choose whichever one
they want to where in fact probably your
intent was or your predecessor's intent
in creating these was that a particular
individual or entity would only fit into
one of them and they would have to align
with that
and there are components of them
where the definition is tied to a
particular amount of money either being
received or expended or received or
expended so some are both some are one
some of the other and so as I understand
the law they don't actually become a
committee until they pass that threshold
so a political advocacy organization is
defined as an entity that spends five
thousand on explicit advocacy
Communications so even though they they
are subject to the reporting of
political committees and there's a law
that says political committees start
reporting when they hit a thousand
they're not a political committee so as
a lawyer I look at that as saying okay
the law has a two-part test
is it a political committee yes or no
and if it is then have they done have
they either received or expended or both
um
or either I should say the threshold
amount of money so a political advocacy
organization as I understand the law
would file its first report after
expending five thousand dollars and only
on that statutorily defined narrow form
of expenditures
one of the things you'll see that's
detailed in this is the question and I'm
not entirely I can as a lawyer I can
craft an answer in either direction does
a political advocacy organization it can
make contributions because your statute
sets a contribution limit for it but is
a contribution an explicit communication
you know we have the Buckley versus
vileo line of federal cases that kind of
say money is speech but it's somewhat
unclear whether the legislature intends
that a political advocacy organization
which it said can make contributions
because you've set limitations on how
much they can provide whether that is
reportable and I think the most courts
that construe campaign Finance statutes
construe them like tax codes and other
things where unless it clearly requires
something that's not required this is
not you make your best guess so what
they're meant to do because it's
restrictive in their in nature
what the courts find is restricted is
just what the legislature has clearly
defined
so the first few pages just go through
the different types of
registrant types one area that I would
encourage you to look carefully at is
the distinctions between a candidate
filing as a candidate and a candidate
filing as a candidate committee
as we understand the law and I detail it
here there are some differences in terms
of how much they can give to somebody
else and some other elements of the law
but and there are differences in when
they have to file reports I would
suggest a good question to think about
is
what are the public policy benefits of
that distinction
and are they outweighed by the harm
caused by the confusion very common
question is all right I'm going to run
for office which of these do I do and do
I need a Treasurer or I need a Fiscal
Agent or do you need both and can they
be the same person
we are a very simple thing that treats
candidates and candidates who choose to
work through a committee identically
would make it easier for folks that are
filing to understand it would make it
easier for folks who want to see where
the money is coming from and going to to
be able to keep track of that
um
we then have these segregated fund
organizations
we are reading into the statute I think
logically and reasonably that to be a
segregated fund political committee you
have to be part of an entity that exists
in some legal form other than being a
political committee and you've got to
have a fund that the political spending
fund is segregated from
so this would not be something that just
folks getting together to be a political
committee would be able to do if their
only existence was as a registered
political committee they need to be
something else and I again I'll leave
the details for either your questions or
or you can read what I've tried to give
you what would be most helpful
um
I think the major purpose electioneering
and the major purpose not electioneering
are areas that one create these
differentials of when you become a
committee that are confusing and hard
for folks to sort out and becomes
enticing for someone that doesn't
understand the structure to pick the one
that gives them the most Liberty I.E
I'll report I'll make myself the one
that doesn't have to report till I hit
the higher amount of funds
um
political advocacy organizations are a
really difficult thing to kind of
understand who they were intended to be
under what circumstances they exist I've
mentioned the issue of whether funds
received for and used to make
contributions to candidates are even
reportable under the system by the
political advocacy organization they
it's not clear that they are under the
statute which probably translates to
that they are not
um
so I provided that on page five item two
an explanation as best I can what I
typically tell folks when I end up on
the phone or talking with them about
should I form a committee or just file
as a candidate what I understand those
distinctions to be
reporting deadlines starting on page six
item three and going forward I've tried
to lay out the reporting deadlines as we
understand them with columns for the
candidate which ones apply in columns
for a candidate committee which also
would apply to any other form of
political Committee in terms of when
folks need to
um
submit their first report
on the bottom of page seven you'll see
there's some highlighted sections this
is probably one of the lighter lifts
that if you chose to you could clean up
the statute
reporting deadlines are sometimes
defined as you report funds received and
expended
up until the Monday preceding the filing
and in other places for other events the
same committee or the same candidate but
later for a different filing period it's
up to and including the Monday before
the statement is due not a huge problem
a lot of people just report the Monday
receipts and it's there but it creates
this if they ask me a question and I
need to give them a precise answer well
which are you and at which filing
deadline are you at to know whether you
stop what you got on Sunday is the last
thing you have to report to later or the
last thing you received on Monday is
part of the required reporting period
there are some duplicative reporting in
the statute some of it may be purposeful
and I'm not suggesting the answer of
whether it should be removed or not but
you should as you consider this be
mindful we have this system that
requires the reporting of independent
expenditures the threshold is a thousand
dollars in the Aggregate and then
there's a 48-hour deadline after the
expenditure to file that report those
independent expenditure reports do not
satisfy as we understand the law the
periodic reporting requirements
so you would file a 48-hour independent
expenditure report you would also have
to include that same expenditure in your
report for the period in which the
expenditure was made that you might be
filing at a subsequent Moment In Time
maybe a good reason for it if not then
I'd encourage you to think about the
pros and cons the benefits versus cost
of the system
the basic structure of the campaign
Finance law as we understand it is once
you trigger a duty to report you're
reporting your receipts and your
expenditures and you have to keep
reporting until you hit zero
so you can go beyond the end of the
election if you have a debt you can go
out and fundraise and raise more money
to pay off that debt but you have to
file every six months until your
accountant hits zero
for many but not all of the folks who
file they are
multi-election cycle participants in the
process and to the extent that they have
a surplus we encourage them to but the
law doesn't require that they close out
I'll use as an example their 2022
registration their accountant when they
open their 2024 and they bring their
their Surplus down to Zero by simply
rolling that money forward we understand
the law to permit that it's important as
you think through this though to
understand that if I'm a Max donor and I
give to somebody I have a limitation
given that my characteristic as a donor
in the 2022 cycle
um
I hit go back to zero for the 2024 cycle
notwithstanding that some of the money
the person might roll or the committee
might roll forward from 22 to 24 might
include funds that came from me
um in the past our understanding of the
Attorney General's approach to this is
that's not violating an a contribution
limit unless there's no circumstance
except that it is an excessive
contribution and most of these entities
have contributions to many people
There's no practical way to or
requirement to account which dollar is
spent where so once it's fungible in a
pool of larger amounts have given the
full 30 000 that I could give or fifteen
thousand depending on my characteristics
but who I gave it to had fifty thousand
and they spent 35 of it the presumption
is going to be that my 15 was part of
the 35 they spent not part of the 15
that rolls into the next year but we are
mindful as we look at the law and try to
provide guidance on it it's our
understanding the Attorney General's
office is mindful to be cautious that
there aren't systematic things permitted
that would allow somebody to go above
the contribution limit but not be
accountable for it one of the areas and
it's addressed in the memo is the issue
of
fundraising after an election to
increase Surplus
so we see some of this we think it's not
proper but it clear is not clearly
prohibited in the statute
and one of the concerns with fundraising
after the election if you have a surplus
as of the election or paying off the
debts that you may have accrued by the
election is that it's a way to go to
your maxed owners or people who might be
Max donors in the next cycle get them to
contribute to the 2022 cycle really just
adding to the Surplus knowing that
you're going to roll that forward but in
a way that doesn't attribute to the
specific contributor
and then that contributor resets to zero
and can again contribute to Max in the
2024 cycle so kind of a fine nuance and
I don't know that we have evidence that
there's any kind of serious or rampant
efforts to contribute beyond the
limitations so maybe a solution in
search for a problem that's your
judgment call to make but I've alerted
you to that nuance and that if it's your
intent that election day when I look at
all my receipts and my expenditures and
the death that I hold at that moment if
I have a surplus I probably shouldn't be
doing a fundraising after election day
that is just going to build my Surplus
more it makes the process of keeping
track of whether somebody contributed
more than they're permitted to at least
very difficult if not impossible and
certainly at the enforcement level
couple of um
well political advocacy organizations
whatever attention you're willing to
give to them if you choose to retain
them in the system anything to help us
all understand what they are would be
greatly appreciated
uh just a couple more items I'm almost
done here item nine
there is a provision in 664 Cullen 4
Roman 5 subsection 5 that says you can't
make a contribution if made without the
knowledge and written consent of the
candidate or his Fiscal Agent a
political committee or its Treasurer and
not to any one of the same
I don't know of anybody who has made a
contribution that goes and asks for a
written permission slip before they do
it I'm not familiar with any campaigns
that have a systematic process of
alerting people that if you'd like to
contribute to me please get this written
permission from me so I think it's a
provisioning law that's not adhered to
widely I'm not sure what its function
and purpose is and would encourage you
to look carefully of whether that's an
area that you might bring that
simplification to
item 10 is uh RSA 664 colon seven
the statute that requires candidates to
report and it has a phrase at the end of
one of the sentences that reads
accepting however the expenditures of
political Committees of the party to
which the candidate belongs in elections
other than primaries I think that could
benefit from some clarification of what
it is that the law is expecting I think
it means in part that an in-kind
contribution made by the political
Committee of a political party so it
could be the Sullivan County Republican
or Democratic committee that is a
political Committee of a political party
that's local and if they hold a
a cookout and they buy the food and have
some expenses with it
if somebody else did that and the
candidate benefited from it it is
arguably at least an in-kind
contribution you have to sort out what
that candidates share of the cost was
candidate would have to report it as an
in-kind contribution I think this phrase
in the sentence means if it's the
political Committee of a political party
then it's not a contribution it doesn't
count towards what the candidate needs
to report the problem comes I think some
of these committees are making Direct
Cash contributions to candidates
and
either one of two things then needs to
be true either that's also Exempted
in which case the candidate brings it in
but either there's no accounting of it
or they have to keep a separate set of
books
for the exempt from reporting money they
bring in and spend
or
um
it's something that should be reported
but it's not clear that it should be in
the wording of that phrase in in that
sentence
probably more of a problem for the
candidate because they're probably going
to book it in
and if they book it in you know they've
got to cover the expense or they're
never going to get to zero they've got
to show how it was expended
um again I've kind of laid it out as
clearly as I think I can but I'm happy
to answer questions at any point in the
process or we are the last item is just
a general recommendation that you look
at at some point in the future we think
the earliest probably should be the 2026
election cycle give us a chance to get
the new system acquired developed and in
place to some extent but requiring most
if not all people with a due to files to
file electronically
um anybody who spent any time looking at
paper filings that we post on our
website will know their utility is
dramatically less than those who file
electronically in part just because you
can't read the numbers
you know and the new cursive required
education in high school maybe we'll
help that out if that becomes law but as
a practical matter having the values the
numbers type makes it more realistic
frankly it's helpful to the filer the
candidate and the committee to the
extent that the campaign Finance system
the old one that's going out has some of
this we're trying to enhance it in the
new one coming in has tools that help
them do the math and keep track and
alert them that says hey you're saying
that bud Fitch you know previously gave
you five thousand for the primary you're
now saying is going to give you another
2 000. he's somebody who's subject the
way you've entered him into the 5000
limit so probably you shouldn't accept
that contribution so they're tools that
can help people who have a duty file be
compliant it certainly makes it easier
for the public or those who are
interested other candidates perhaps in
who raised how much from whom to have
numbers that they can actually read and
understand online line would assist that
finally and it's in that section 11 the
default starting point under the statute
as we understand it is everything that's
turned into US is completely public and
anybody for any reason kind of a right
to know law standard can come and look
at that information to the extent we get
it up on the website
they can from wherever they want to go
there and they can use it for any
purpose that they want to there's no
constraint on how this information is
used
one of the things that would be helpful
to us is to have the ability to either
encourage or require followers to
provide
a way to contact them cell phone number
and email address but we know that many
people either use the ones they don't
have any time to get to for email
addresses or they have one but they're
careful who gets it so it doesn't become
a source of spam or unwanted attention
so the legislature has in other areas
created an exemption to the right to no
law for phone numbers and emails
provided to the Secretary of State's
office or local election officials with
the purpose of getting information about
elections so that is such that the fact
that you email us or call us as a
citizen asking us questions
would be of interest to somebody running
a campaign because that flags that
person as somebody who probably is going
to go vote and is interested enough to
be making inquiries today before that
law was passed somebody could have done
a right to no law requested us and we
would have been obligated to go find all
those emails or cell phone numbers or
phone numbers and give them out
we requested the legislature made the
law in that instance one that Exempted
it consider whether if we
add to the information presented to us
give us your cell phone number we can
reach you or your email address whether
we can exempt it it is more realistic
for electronic filing because we simply
build the system to not have it report
that field on the things the public and
others can look at on paper
actually please don't make it exempt
because we then would have to pay human
beings to go and create a redaction on
the PDF scan of the filing in order for
it to not be disclosed unless it was
disclosed in some separate way
those are the highlights
thanks bud
um let me just give you a real-time
uh example of the confusion that is out
there that I've been Fielding calls on
this topic uh this week and it's more
than just a couple
um
tomorrow six month reports are due
and a six-month report is a report that
is required to be filed
every six months by a candidate or a
political committee
that has not renewed its committee
after the past election
so if there is a surplus or a negative
balance in a campaign account
the candidate or the committee is
responsible for filing six months
six-month reports until a zero balance
is reached at which point a final report
is filed and there's no further
obligation to file the report
if a
candidate creates a candidate committee
or a political committee is created for
the 2024 cycle
then
a a balance that is left over from the
last election
can be transferred to the new committee
and then a final report can be filed
for the past election
and there's no further obligation to
file a six-month report
new committees that are created are
required to file their first report in
June of this year
and so there is a lot of confusion about
you know what do you have to file when
do you have to file it how do you
transfer the funds
to achieve that zero balance
and I think that if we can just
consolidate those filing dates and make
the transfer of balances to a new
committee when it is renewed automatic
it would eliminate a lot of confusion
and headaches and and unintentional
violations of the statute because the
proper report didn't get filed
I know that and I don't see the Attorney
General's office represented here but I
would definitely suggest that you have
them come in and offer their suggestions
because they are the ones that are
responsible for the enforcement of the
election law statutes including campaign
Finance
and they just sent a round of letters
out within the last month
for reports that were not filed or
properly filed from the 2020 election
cycle
and you know we're getting the calls
from that saying you know we don't have
those records anymore you know what do
we do we don't want to you know we don't
want to be in trouble and so you know I
I think that
um
you know a more timely action when it's
required is is better but I think we can
eliminate a lot of the confusion and the
need for the Attorney General's actions
if we just simplify these statutes make
it easier for compliance
um
and I I think that's your goal as well
so
um thank you well I was one of those who
called Matt yesterday
for exactly this reason because I have a
surplus and most of it's from my own
because it's also not clear if when I
sell fund if I'm supposed to put that in
that's another area of confusion is do
we want to or
transparency do we want to require
people who self-fund to at least show
that and the amount not to put a limit
on it but it's in different parts of the
statute but I guess my question was when
I went into the system there was no
clear place for me to put that overage
in and I put in an amount and then all
of a sudden it bumped it up another I
met five hundred dollars
um
so I just filed it and said I hope this
is the right way to do it because I was
so confused so I agree with you that we
need to
fix that but I would also like any
thoughts and I saw
you know Mr Fitch reaching for the thing
about self-financing and do we should
push it back in my direction
[Laughter]
if I may so just a couple things to keep
in mind first the case law suggests that
the acceptable reason for regulating
what is otherwise First Amendment Free
Speech political advertising to the
whole Foundation of campaign Finance law
is one of anti-corruption and disclosure
and the courts have very clearly said I
can't corrupt myself
so you have a limited ability under the
Constitution to regulate how much of my
money I spend for myself There's No
Limit I can spend as much of my own
money as I want to as a candidate I'm
seeking election and I would seek
guidance from the Attorney General's
office and tread carefully on on kind of
how much you regulate that the current
system certainly requires that if you
report it you've got to then keep
dealing with it being there until such
time as you expend it all so you reach
that magic zero amount to transfer
complexities are these systems Drive
many candidates to loan their campaign
money
so they're taking money out of their
pocket they're putting it in they hope
they get more popular with contributors
and at some point they could repay that
debt back to themselves and other people
really underwrite the cost of the
campaign so it's fairly common to see in
reports that a candidate has loaned
himself or herself money
so then when they're in the circumstance
you describe them I'm at the end of that
and you know you're going to run again
you probably want to roll it over and
move it forward but if you're not
you can't normally just pay yourself the
Surplus but you could if you had booked
it as a loan to your campaign you also
can forgive the loan at some point to
get it off the books if yep I spent it
it was my money but I'm done and I'm
just going to forgive the loan which
post-hoc converts it to being a
self-contribution
so there are a host of complexities
under the current statute that address
those concerns we are working we're
literally still hammering out the terms
of the contract we were working to make
the new campaign Finance system be have
enhanced help
and to be easier to deal with those
kinds of transitions that happen I just
note secretary scalin talked about the
complexity of the transition period
one thing that can happen to the law
does happen is I can have a 2022
committee that has debt
that doesn't prevent me there's nothing
in the law that prevents me from opening
a 2024 committee and depending upon who
I owe that debt to if it's a friendly
person who loaned it to me who's not
after me to pay it off there may be
reasons that I want to raise new money
for 2024 without paying off the debt
from 2022 so everything Dave said layer
on top of that that you are
simultaneously reporting for your 2022
that has debt well you're now having to
report for your 2024 that's coming in
and you've got to keep track with your
donors when you get money from them
which that's for and you know the law is
pretty flexible if you have a cookout
and there's a basket and some of your
contributions just come with people who
are dropping checks into it or dropping
cash into it which is common in my
experience what happens pretty much the
law leaves it up to somebody to
determine
how that money was contributed was it
for an exploratory phase was it for
primary phase was it for the general
phase and if you are somebody that has
both a last cycle debt committee open
and a new cycle fundraising committee
open presumably unless they write on the
check you know bud Fitch for dog catcher
2024 which would signal that the donors
intent is to constrain it to that you as
a candidate or whoever is doing that for
the committee could sort that through
and I'll just quickly throw in another
area you can think about is
the federal law for campaign Finance has
a pretty structured process for when you
get money that you need to give back
the state law is completely silent on it
I think the benefit of a system like the
federal system that gives you a window
of opportunity in which you can do that
and there's no harm no foul recognizes
the reality that as in the scenario I
just described your you or whoever
manages your funds is going through the
basket you know maybe a day or two after
the picnic before you realize that
somebody gave you a check that is maxed
out and so you need to give it back to
them but you want to get it booked and
you have some duty to report it if
there's an imminent deadline coming up
but you also want to get booked into
that system how you give it back
adopting some Provisions that describe
what is the permissible period of time
in which you have in which to refund a
contribution that's not permissible
would make things easier to understand
and clear and set a boundary for okay
it's been more than 60 days you've had
time to get it back or 90 days or
whatever you might choose I think the
federal was at one time at least 60 days
thank you
thank you I also want to uh
say that 40 of the five reps here had a
problem
similar to representative Lane because I
made a similar the details were a little
different but I made a similar call
yesterday and
the best I can say is I made a good a
good faith effort to comply
but I'm still don't understand the
proper procedure
any questions from our committee
subcommittee oh yeah I
I'll
okay representative Muirhead how many
years did you devote to studying physics
I don't even want to say it was a long
long time and it seemed even longer
follow-up
certainly so if this is difficult for
you to understand how to comply them and
can presume that people
is difficult for everybody I I think
that's valid yes
representative Lane uh
um
you talked about streamlining these
different kinds of committees
and I guess
how do we do I'm a little concerned
about how we would do that because the
Committees are often created for very
different purposes we have packs super
Pacs we have people who are end up doing
independent expenditures
we have
so I don't know how to streamline them
because I want to make sure because we
are after transparency and disclosure so
do we just say everybody discloses no
matter what your purpose is
I think the answer to that is yes when I
first started working in the Secretary
of State's office and it's more than 20
years ago now that the definition of
political committee was pretty simple it
was two or more persons organized
for the purpose of supporting or
opposing you know a candidate or measure
on the ballot and and ever since then
there's just been all of these
additional uh
Provisions placed in there and you know
it seems to me that
that a committee that is going to be
engaged
in the campaign process
one way or the other
could be just a single filing
just just you know it's it's a committee
that is engaged in political activity
during campaign season
and then there may be different types of
expenditures uh
um independent expenditures or
whatever there may have to be a separate
uh entity for political advocacy
because because of federal laws and
court cases uh you know if they're if if
an organization is a
uh
551c4 five or six whatever I mean they
don't have to list their contributors
but they should still list the amount of
money that that they have raised
without those identifiers if they choose
to keep that information private
it just seems to me that that it's you
know that the transparent
part of this should be
the money that was raised and the money
that was spent
and categorizing those funds so they you
know they're appropriately uh
divulged
and then having reporting deadlines that
are
uniform and simple and I think if we can
streamline
that as much as possible it will benefit
everyone and there are different
thresholds as Bud mentioned in the
statute for you know when that
particular entity currently kicks in
as a as a political committee I mean
just make it just make a one just you
know have a have a single threshold
excuse me and uh
you know have you know allow for
generous contributions maybe eliminate
the different phases of exploratory
primary General and just you know allow
a single contributor to give x amount of
dollars
per election you know to a candidate
um
and I think if we can do that it will be
just simpler for everybody to understand
the process and the transparency that
everybody wants to see would certainly
be there
if I can just add in
um
there's a statue that says committees
have to report when they pass the
threshold there's a statute that says
candidates have to report when they pass
the threshold both are defined terms the
law talks about exploratory committees
there's no statute that says an
exploratory candidate has any duty to
file a receipts and expenditure report
even though there are constraints on how
much they can take in and
part of the struggle is that we live in
a world where a lot of the people active
are also active federally and federally
a Super PAC is a defined entity in their
law in New Hampshire I try to push the
word political committee it's not even a
political action committee because
that's not how you've defined it in the
law to try to help people think that
okay if I'm talking state I'm not
talking Super PAC or pack or 524 or any
of the multiple ways people have figured
out how to move money federally I'm just
talking about a plain a political
committee now I may be talking about a
political advocacy organization we've
made it more complex than it was when I
first started working in it but it's
there and I think that's part of the
reality really active people who are
well intentioned have got it into their
mind that there are things that exist
because they exist in the federal side
that exist on the state side when in
fact they don't
um and that's part of the challenge of
the complexity of the statute
um I I spent the weekend rereading ours
and trying to come up with a list and uh
and we spent the last meeting doing the
same thing but yours is much much better
so thank you so much
um
I guess part of me says why do we need a
threshold is that something that we see
across other states is that
why is there a threshold do we need it
uh if if I can I believe the threshold
exists because there's frankly an amount
of money changing hands to promote
somebody's candidacy or to oppose it
that just doesn't matter if we're
concerned about undue influence and
we're concerned about knowing who our
elected officials are influenced by
um if I may use a State Rep who runs a
600 campaign as an example is it really
public interest or concern about that
other than maybe the person running
against her or him in the campaign but
as a general proposition
people volunteering to take a hundred
dollar a year job that takes tons and
tons of hours probably isn't going to be
unduly influenced by less than 600 or
less than a thousand dollars of money
coming and going so my understanding of
the legislative intent and having
thresholds is in part that there are
levels below which the public policy
purpose for having the disclosure
aren't satisfied because there's just
not public interest the
goal of having disclosure so that if
somebody's unduly influenced by a
particular contributor or set of
contributors with a particular point of
view this isn't going to happen below a
certain threshold of money
yes representative Ross thank you
um
I have a couple uh
just while we've got you
um how long does it take your office to
turn around paper filings or filings
that come in not to the cfis system
whenever they're filing deadlines due
and we receive the filings it I think
that information gets scanned in pretty
much the same day if not it's just a
couple of days we get it up fairly
quickly
foreign
I have a question What proportion of the
filings are by paper instead of online
thank you
I'm going to have to get a
get that information to you what what I
think that uh we are going to reach a
point where it will be important for the
legislature to decide
that electronic filings are mandatory uh
what happens now is that even with some
of the major candidates and I'm talking
uh you know at the top level candidates
believe that there is some benefit to
not making their donor list easily
acceptable
and so some of them still file their
reports on paper
and not only that in between filings we
see font changes we see spreadsheet
columns change
things that make even the paper filings
difficult to follow
um and so you know part of the
part of the process of being transparent
uh and disclosure allows
the general public to easily View and
search
for items that they're looking for and
so as long as the major candidates are
not all uniformly providing the
information into the electronic database
you get some information but you're not
you're not able to see the whole picture
but again that's a that's a legislative
decision to finally
you know go all the way and make it
mandatory as opposed to giving the
option
so uh thank you so what I'm hearing here
is that some submissions
you're certainly not saying it's
deliberate but is it's almost as if it
were an attempt to make it more
difficult for people to
to receive the information that they're
supposed to be provided it says it's
it's almost that bad yeah okay thank you
yes representative representative just
to resp just to return to the ques the
question of the difference between the
federal category safer committees and
the state categories would it would one
of the would it be a correct takeaway to
say that it'd be an advantage if
um
campaign Finance law and the state used
the same categories as exist in federal
campaign law or is that just an option
I would be cautious with that approach
just because
while it's on its face or at the top
level surface the federal system is
somewhat simpler than ours once you dig
in a little bit it is not at all and so
because of the use of the 501c4 through
whatever categories because of the
different IRS provisions and its 524s
are one that was popular at one point I
don't know if they used as much in this
day and age there are a bunch of ways to
do the things that our political
committees do under the federal system
that bring them outside of kind of the
usual rules and then they do recognize
both political action committees and
super political action committees
um so I don't know that that's simpler
what I do know having spent a little
time in my lifetime in in that area
um
there's a whole lot more money being
involved in most of the campaigns of any
significance have staff attorneys staff
accountants who only do campaign Finance
work under the federal law I mean it's a
very complicated thing and certainly we
have some high-level office where
there's likely enough money to fund that
sort of thing but we also have State Rep
and County attorney and sure phrases
that are subject to the same set of laws
where
Sheriff shouldn't have to hire an
attorney or a CPA to report her or his
campaign Finance disclosures
yes I want to go back to the mandatory
online filing because as I've said
before this is something that I'm
actually a supporter of for a variety of
reasons is there a reason why you make
your recommendation on your last page of
is is there I I publicated I would love
it if we eat it in the next election so
kind of like what's the why are we why
are we why is your office's
recommendation three years out and not
the next year
we're currently operating the old system
we're in the Contracting phase
negotiating a contract for the new
system and well our goal is to have it
available when the serious
entries happen for 2024 I've never been
involved in rolling out a online
complicated database and Reporting
System that didn't have lots of problems
and glitches that you have to work
through making it mandatory at a point
when you know that you're probably it's
not going to be 100 smooth we're going
to do the best we can we have High Hopes
um that making it mandatory at a point
when we can reasonably expect it to be
settled down and most of the problems
haven't been found and addressed I think
drove our 2026 recommendation
foreign
to that
um I want to go over to
the exploratory candidates
it's another issue that I've raised is I
I just don't believe that's a that
should be a real thing unless you're
actively actually exploring it I think
there was a union leader article this
last week about they called it a
loophole
so it can you kind of dig into that a
little bit I mean I know it's somebody
they haven't made themselves into a
candidate yet because they haven't said
I am running
but they're actively raising funds in
this case we have a candidate who's
exploring who's raised a hundred
thousand dollars
um a person I would make the statement
that you're not exploring at that point
if you've got six figures in your bank
account but
um can you kind of elaborate on like
what would be I would love to close that
up just for the record I would just love
to close that up would maybe this is a
question more for the secretary but if
we were to Define exploratory
would your office be amenable to if we
made it something like you can't raise
or spend more than five thousand after
that you're not exploring
if I'll start answering and then
secretary may have something more to add
to it so as I have experienced the
history and I don't represent myself to
know every element of it this is
something that evolved slowly over time
and there were people going back many
cycles who weren't sure what they wanted
to run or not and they wanted to do some
polling they wanted to test polling this
is higher level State offices test some
of the ideas that they wanted to advance
and to see how well received they would
be before they made the decision to
actually become a candidate so that's my
understanding of how it evolved and then
it became exactly I think what you've
described and not a third bite at the
Apple an opportunity earlier in the
process to get your major supporters
folks that are willing to give you as
much as the law lets you get from them
to make some early contributions and
even though it might not yet be time to
start running ads which I think that
date has moved further and further back
in time from the actual election over
the last couple decades
that you could pay somebody your team
that's going to develop your ads there's
work to be done that you needed money to
pay for that evolved there so one
Point second point when does somebody
become a candidate so we have a statute
that defines a candidate and says you
become a candidate when you declare
yourself as one we have an attorney
general's office opinion or statement of
its application of the law that as far
as I know is still being applied it
dates back I think it was Phil
McLaughlin those who remember back that
far was the Attorney General where it
came out who said this is too
complicated
so if I'm making a speech and I say I'm
thinking about running for dog catcher
am I a candidate I plan to run for dog
catcher my candidate I'm going to file
and seek election as dog catcher I'm a
candidate
somebody can't be expected to have a
Philadelphia lawyer beside them and
coaching them as they make public
statements whether it's in a speech or
to a reporter or however and have that
be the determinant of that they became a
candidate and from an enforcement
perspective you know isn't realistic
that you're going to send out
investigators to question or try to find
audio video tapes of the statements the
candidate made and then parse it to see
so the Attorney General's office said
four campaign Finance purposes you're
going to become a candidate when you
file for office in June
and until you do
we're not going to treat that as that
and I think that also promoted the
recognition of okay but I've got to
raise money and do things before then in
the current environment while you're an
exploratory candidate until you do that
until you make that formal declaration
with the Secretary of State's office to
officially become a candidate federally
I think there is I've looked at this for
a while so check it at one time there
was a dollar amount if you raise or
spend more than x dollars you're a
candidate without consideration to
whether you've made the decision to
formally declare or not so I think there
are other approaches to setting that
boundary but frankly the simplest one is
the one the secretary has suggested
let's eliminate exploratory primary
General you can raise money you have to
report who you got it from and then the
public and your opponents and the press
and everybody that's interested in that
can look at how much that is and if they
think you're taking too much from a
particular Source or a particular
interest group or whatever that becomes
part of the political debate secretary
yeah and just and just more broadly the
interest of our office is
that we have a lot
that is easy to administer
and so you know our concern is
transparency
simplicity
the ability to explain how the law works
and and to train the users you know
issues related to
you know when a person should become a
candidate you know when can they really
start raising funds you know I think
those are policy decisions
uh
to be made by the legislature that are
Beyond
I think our role in the process and so
um we just want to be able to administer
it be able to explain it and be able to
enforce it
um
and then you guys get to decide that you
know the extra cricketer stuff
thank you um welcome just to restate
that it seems maybe possible for the
purposes of campaign Finance if we don't
have people declare a register as
candidates or candidate committees at
all we just say any person or group that
that raises or spends X dollars
for the sake of exploring or advancing a
candidate or a measure must report that
to the Secretary of State's office and
then for campaign Finance all these
distinctions just go away it's only our
people are groups raising or spending X
dollars
that's making it pretty simple it uh
the
um I mean there is you know that there
is a line somewhere uh when you have an
individual
that is going to spend a lot of their
own money on multiple candidates
and you know it
what point does that person remain an
individual just simply giving
contributions or is there a point where
that person becomes
you know a committee that's trying to
influence the outcome of election I you
know that that's that's an area for for
you to talk about but you know as I
mentioned before it's just you know if
we can just have a simple set of
uh
statutes that Define
the reporting process
um
it will be better for everyone
I have a question gentlemen
uh at what point do attempts to regulate
speech which is what political
campaigning is do you have a feel for
when that comes up against the right to
free speech guarantee by the First
Amendment we just
heard of a thought of someone
raising money to get a message out on
political matters but that seems to be
the heart of what's protected by the
First Amendment so
how do we sort out where that hard limit
because if you're going to put in
statute there has to be a hard limit at
some point that's defined how do we sort
that out
it's a general question but do you have
some thoughts
certainly the courts seem to have looked
at what is the permissible purpose for
regulating free speech and they have
recognized that letting the public know
who is funding campaigns and candidates
in the interest of discouraging or
making transparent if there's undue
influence is permissible I mean we treat
candidates and measures about the same
in our law I no one's ever challenged
that proposition but certainly there are
other contexts where the regulation of
money saying vote yes or no on this
constitutional question is viewed
differently because how do you corrupt
a constitutional question
right
you know when you give money to a
candidate and maybe you have a personal
business interest or whatever and
there's a theory that for some donors
and for some candidates there's an
amount of money that if you give them
enough that's going to influence how
they act in their public office based on
that contribution that's what the whole
system is designed to recognize the
courts have said yep the public at least
gets to know about it
um in order to
discourage and bring to light that kind
of undue influence not sure this
argument would ultimately survive on a
measure
thank you
so in the uh obviously I have to go and
step out and do a work thing here in two
minutes so I apologize if we're still
around after 20 minutes I'll be back but
I want to get this in before I have to
go into the hundred dollars a year you
know it just doesn't go that far
um
so we have three core organizations
in general we've got Pax parties and
candidates right and from that we have
various splits so one of the things that
we could do is consolidate that I think
consolidating parties is pretty easy I
think consolidating candidates is pretty
easy
um
Consulting packs should be easy with the
exception of the
citizens united decision so kind of
assuming we wanted to consolidate that
which I imagine there would actually
probably be some consensus on this how
would we consolidate political action
committees and still be in compliance
with the citizen United decision
so I haven't read citizens united for a
while my recollection of it it basically
says that corporations that at one time
were prohibited from making political
contributions were recognized as persons
and could and so if you say whoever you
are
you have to report the money you get
from them and we set some
limit maybe a single one for everything
that's fairly high it's unclear to me
you may understand it better than I do
and maybe there is some thing that
implicates citizens united but I don't
think it does if Corporation can give
money and you treat them like a person
or like a committee you know which a
political committees sometimes have a
legal existence other than being a
political committee but most of them are
don't so that's their sole entity causes
them trouble when they try to get a bank
account but that's a whole separate
discussion
um so I I don't immediately I cannot
identify for you a boundary that
citizens united creates
well a follow-up that's absolutely not a
follow-up because it's um I'm just going
full add brain right now
um
uh parties and candidates
so when a party sends out a mailer that
is not authorized by the candidate the
disclaimer has to be you know paid for
by so-and-so political
um you know State committee
um not authorized by any candidate or
candidates committee
but then there's nothing in there that
says the candidate couldn't authorize it
with their own party and then we don't
have to say there's nothing in the
provision says authorized by the
candidate or candidates committee is
there a re do we know why that's not
it's just a huge gray area right so if
they leave that off as it's to be
inferred that the candidate approved of
the mailer or you see what I'm trying to
get at like is that another area that's
confusing because it definitely
confusing to me I'll start answering in
Secretary may want to add to it yes it's
confusing and if you can make it more
clear it certainly would help people
sort through that I think that my
understanding of kind of the background
of what's going on is the basic concept
is that if a candidate and somebody else
paying for communications that benefits
the candidate coordinate in any way it's
an in-kind contribution
and then I brought your attention to
earlier the reporting statute for
candidates has this phrase that I'm not
entirely sure what it's meant to do and
nor what a court would ultimately find
that it does do that says you don't have
to report things that are done by the
political Committee of a political party
which could be the state party but it
also could be one of the multitude of
town and County and other political
Committees of political parties that
exist there are quite a number of them
out there
um
I hope that's helpful uh Sherman I'll be
back in 20 minutes just so you know I
have to go like pay the bills
um thank you uh
headed back to candidate versus
candidate committee
you know I face this we all face this
when we start to run and I think
particularly in reps not all reps are
small campaigns but most of them are
is there a reason that we need to
differentiate or
is there some
reason that people do that
I think that is a part of the statute
that has just evolved over a long period
of time that yeah there was a period of
time before there were political
committees
and
Canada's just reported to the extent
they had to report as a candidate and
so the candidate statute continued to
the present time even though you know
there was a new additional of candidate
committee and I think you're right that
there are many candidates for State Rep
that just run as individual candidates
and don't file a committee it doesn't
make much sense for them to do that but
I think when you get to the Senate you
know the major candidates there all have
candidate committees and I think that
you know the parties strongly suggest
that they create one and and donors
frankly
like to know that they're contributing
money to an entity as opposed
to just giving money to a person
sometimes
I don't want to monopolize but what
from a if we make reporting consistent
for everybody you know do you make it
and and you can put in a threshold
amount
they make it the first time and then do
you have them do it quarterly I mean
what what when you say consistently or
at the same time from a disclosure
standpoint is there a Feeling
how often do you need to do that during
the election cycle
that that is a determination of the
legislature okay um
prior to maybe six years ago or eight
years ago the the reporting schedule was
directly related
to proximity to the election
and so reports were required uh one week
before the election three weeks before
the election
and that it might have been eight weeks
before the election I think that's still
in the statute
but then a more recent legislature
decided that they also wanted to have
reports filed in the year before the
election
uh in June and December I believe so
that created you know a additional
requirements but also
um
you know at the same time they didn't
try and sink that in with a six-month
reports that are filed so you know now
we have a report that's due tomorrow for
six months reports and then there'll be
another report due a month later in June
when committees that have
filed uh after make their first report
of the 2024 election cycle
do we have further questions
representative Muirhead
um thank you on the difference between a
candidate committee and a candidate just
looking at this and now realize that the
candidate is triggered you know to
encourage a responsibility to report
when the candidate has ex has spent
money a thousand dollars including of
just spending their own money
but yazooved explained it as you've
explained it that the courts say that um
candidates can't corrupt themselves so
in principle there's no public reason to
force people to show how they're
spending their money if it's their money
and and the public really has right to
know who candidates are getting money
from so one possibility would be to
eliminate the candidate reporting of
spending their own money and say that
candidates have a you know duty to
report only when they receive money from
others whatever that threshold might be
could be low it could be zero
I I think you're right you're
identifying an option that's available
to you I would think about that option
in light of our experience in the last
couple decades where there are some
pretty major self-funded campaigns and
do you want a circumstance where
somebody who's not rich is running and
raising money and spending it and
there's lots of transparency about
what's coming and going and their
opponent is somebody who's sufficiently
wealthy to spend millions of dollars and
posts as well who's paying for that
where is that's coming from and if
there's nothing reported
you can draw an inference well they must
be self-funding but you know that I know
federally there's been lots of cases and
challenges and I frankly don't even know
the current state of the law it's going
to be the candidates money but does that
conclude The candidate's spouse's money
does it include the candidate's parents
money I mean you may have read the same
stories I have where somebody's dad gave
them some money for their campaign and
was Dad kind of them or is that a
separate entity who's subject to the
constraints and how much can be given so
I think there's a rationale to support
some level of reporting but I think
you've identified as an option that's
available
thank you I really appreciate that
um nothing like being an expert
uh I have one other question that's okay
I'm also curious about whether you think
there's a rationale for the difference
between category four political
committee segregated organ you know
organization fund and
um political number six for the many
major purpose not electioneering
I do not I mean I I
change jobs along the way I used to do a
lot of this campaign Finance when I
worked at the AG's office I did some
other jobs for a while I came back when
I went to work for the Secretary of
State and frankly was a little bit
unclear in my mind why some of these
categories were created and what the
objectives were using the words that
were put into the law I've done my best
to try to understand them
but I don't I don't have a good answer
to you thank you and there is no
requirement in the statute that
candidates actually have to create a
separate
bank account for their campaign funds
they can they can run it through their
personal finances as long as they keep
good records of what's going where
certainly if we're asked the question we
would recommend that a candidate open an
account where you know
where the funds are separate
um just to kind of keep them out of
trouble down the road
but then there are larger entities like
you know labor unions cannot
according to the statute make
contributions to candidate directly from
the union treasury they can do it if
they create a political committee
and so an entity like that
it might make sense to have a segregated
fund for the political committee
it might be a good idea for corporations
which are as Bud said treated as
individuals to also have you know a
separate account for that purpose but
um
that's that's just the state of our
statute
thank you
additional questions
yes please
we haven't
been since on this but one of the things
that I've been working on is that when
an LLC gives money
they're often created just to give money
and they can give and they're then their
members whether they're corporations or
individuals and it's a way to get around
the individual
um cap so that I could give ten thousand
dollars if that's the maximum and then
if Russ and I do an LLC we can each give
another ten thousand to the same one but
it's through that entity so as an
individual we've gone over our limit and
both Democrats and Republicans have used
this to raise a lot of money in our
state and in other states it's not just
New Hampshire
so my font is
how would that fit in if we have these
various
disclosure pieces
how would that fit in I'm trying to fit
it into this new rubric that we are
working on how does that how would that
fit in or do you know or is it am I just
speculating too much I'll try to avoid
any speculation
um I mean I think the question
might be most helpful with thought
process maybe step back what are we
trying to achieve we're trying to
achieve making information available to
the public to voters and less directly
but probably more pertinently to the
opposing candidate or the opposing
candidates party the people who are
watching the process and trying to be
alert for things that they think the
voters should be alerted to of what's
coming and going in that respect and so
I I don't nope
excuse me
um I don't um
I think the complexity of trying to sort
out because it's llc's but if you form a
corporation the corporation is an
independent person
um if you look at the corporate
structure of even relatively simple
corporations people
in New Hampshire that are in the Housing
Industry where they're doing rental
properties most of them for very prudent
civil liability reasons have each of
those tied up in a separate legal
corporate entity and if they're in a
position where they control the
decisions that makes it may be an
insurmountable burden to try to carve
out some further constraint on that and
if there's complete transparency
some theories of campaign Finance
regulation are as long as it's
transparent let those who think it's not
appropriate for somebody who owns who
controls 10 corporations and each makes
individual contributions simply Drive
The public's attention to that
um I'm not sure if that answers your
question you want to
just to follow up and I guess the
intuition is that you could create a
legal entity so I as a person am limited
and how much I can give my fellow
representative for his re-election
campaign but if I if I then create a
legal entity that hides the fact that I
gave it money
or doesn't list me as a contributor and
that legal entity call it an LLC or just
you know
new court or something gives my my my
friend you know money that I've been
able to to exceed the the you know
contribution limits by creating this
thing and making my identity opaque
so so is you know wouldn't be enough
just to inform the public that I made a
contribution up to the Limit and then
that I contributed to new court which
made another contribution because that
would just be telling the public that
I've escaped the contribution limits
um I I would still have succeeded at
escaping the contribution limit so do
you think there's a a good reason to
somehow restrict people's ability to
kind of give to pass through entities
that then allow them to escape these
thresholds
I think a challenge that you face and it
isn't a good answer to your question but
it's the best one I can offer off the
top of my head is that if you closed the
multiple Corporation process you could
probably somebody Desiring to do what
your hypothetical describes could do the
same thing through a political committee
or through one of the
501c456 kind of entities that exist that
may or may not become a political
committee as long as there are enough
people willing to do it so that their
record of their contributions from you
show that this isn't just you doing it
um
they're probably going to achieve that
end goal
the other thing that I would say that
you know part of this process is going
to involve political decisions uh policy
decisions that
uh you know I don't think that that's a
particular point that my office is
interested in answering I think that's
something that the legislature has to
decide we're more concerned about
the the framework for that you know the
you know again the Simplicity
transparency and and a process that's
easy to administer
and you guys get to tie the bow on it
yes
and I appreciate that I might be asking
questions that really aren't strictly
speaking you know germane to the work of
your office and therefore feel free to
just pass on them but I appreciate you
know there's a level of expertise and
intimacy with the details of this really
vexing area that just trying to extract
some some of that wisdom even if it's
not necessarily and what I'm kind of
hearing here is that
for really sophisticated donors Big Time
donors the contribution limits can be
escaped you can always create some sort
of legal thing that allows you to escape
them and so
um there I've heard people say we should
just go for transparency and not try to
cap donations because that water is
always going to find its way downhill
and there's no way to stop it and I'm
not saying that that's your you know
settled All Things Considered viewer
that the Secretary of State's office
should even have a view about that but
but if if there is a view I guess given
all the expertise all the things you've
seen about whether contribution limits
ultimately are kind of impossible to
enforce I'd be interested to hear it
yeah
at some point
um
you know letting the free market go if I
can use that term it you know is it's
probably a good thing but but the other
the other uh
kind of abstract part of this is
the you want to make sure the candidates
can compete and that they have a fair
shot and granted
speech is money but you know money can
can buy a lot of influence and uh
you know I think that's a different
issue
um that is a part of this discussion
and you know the question is how do you
you know how do you maintain a
relatively Fair playing field you know
for the candidates that are going to
participate in the election process
okay any other questions at this point
please
I just want to thank you this has been
really helpful and
um I we will be taking you up on your
offer
I don't know if that included Mr Fish or
not but
well I've been saying that you know we
need to really take a look at that part
of the statute you know the whole
chapter for
for years and it seems like
this is a good opportunity to really
finally dig into it
yes thank you for being here and I also
found it very helpful also having a
write-up because trying to
take adequate notes on such a
interesting and involved discussion is
impossible
and I I do have the distinct impression
from your
speaking with us today that
the emphasis of the Secretary of State's
office is really to have a set of
statutes that are unambiguous and clear
and don't have conflicts and therefore
are not confusing
and you and I can see where you would
draw a clear distinction between that
and policy questions so thank you again
very much I know you're well we're all
very busy but you guys are particularly
busy in your office and thank you for
taking the time to speak with us
okay
well this is I find this very useful
myself
that's
and do you know whether the Attorney
General's office will be visiting this
working group no seriously not well
representative Lane has has made a
distinct effort
to get in touch with them and so far
hasn't completed the connection
for reasons Beyond her control so I
heard from him the other day maybe I
could maybe I maybe they'll answer my
call now the short version of my answer
is uh it's been being worked on
and we're hopeful that we will hear from
them
and I only ask that I mean again because
the questions about what can be
administered by the Secretary of State's
office are vital but also what can be
enforced and that's we're asking I was
asking questions about what can we
enforce in the Secretary of State you
know is wisely saying that's not what we
do right but of course it is what the AG
does
yep
so we have uh
37 minutes left in the time we have
scheduled for today and
how would uh
how would we as a committee like to make
best use of that do you want to pick up
where we ended go ahead
I have to confess I have a I have to be
back in Hanover at once I'm gonna have
to leave at quarter up and I don't have
as much time as anyone else all right
thank you for letting me know
and his representative Ross
we just concluded our visit with the
Secretary of State in perfect timing Mr
Fitch
and the question is where would we like
to go for the next uh half hour or so
with this meeting
are you asking me I'm asking for your
opinion yes
um this is a committee means a joint
outfit and that's I I honestly I'd like
to hear kind of people's thoughts
um because this is obviously a very
campaign Finance heavy side of it the
actual money side of it I'd like to kind
of gather what everybody's thoughts are
or like preliminary ideas
I'm happy to start off with what my
thoughts are but I think I said
something to the secretary but I kind of
like to know
find I guess find some early years of
consensus if you will I like that
Network yeah all right please begin
um so I uh I wholeheartedly agree with
the overarching concept which is we
should streamline this down
make it consistent across the board so
things that I think
I'd like to see is
you know one donation one contribution
limit for all various organizations so
Pacs candidates committees parties
across the board whatever that number is
we can haggle over that number if it
wants to go up down stay the same meet
in the middle whatever
um I I think I could definitely get on
board it just being one number
um I I can definitely get on board with
getting rid of the multitude of
different organizations and going down
to three
um Pax parties and candidates
um and then I think one of the things we
should look at closing is
um not allowing candidates to set up
um committees specifically for one year
um so I think I think a candidate or a
candidates committee what everyone end
up calling them should be tied to that
individual candidate and it just carries
until they get to their zero balance so
they can't do Berry 2022 Barry 2024 or
Barry 2026 it's just Barry for New
Hampshire
you see what I'm saying so they can't do
the they can't debt load they can't
basically use debt load as a way to get
around contribution issues
yeah would you say that one more time
so one of the things you talked about
which was a very nuanced way of
um
it kind of Dodge I don't say dodging but
because it's not really dodging it's
just not
in the spirit of the law if you will
um is they'll set up uh organizations
that live and die cycle to cycle and
instead of that just making it
as long as you are an active candidate
seeking office or intending to seek
office or actively raising money
that is your organization so it's not
very very 2022 it's barrier for New
Hampshire barrier for New Hampshire
operates until Bradford New Hampshire
hits zero
um I think another one just on the dates
um I would I would love to see the sixth
month
raising money after the election I I
think is ridiculous
you know I could see a world in which
it's like
a week if you have you know you gotta
pay off whatever but I think after a
week you're on to the next cycle we're
on to the next thing so I think that's
an area of
just in that and move on and you're on
if you raise money a week after the
general election you are now raising
money for the next election
um I I think that would fit in with the
idea of just having a committee that
continually exists until it goes to zero
well you have to have a cycle reset date
because if you don't because the
contribution limits correct you have to
so you have to have a cycle reset date
so right now our cycle reset date is
like six months after the election which
is ridiculous or I think it's December
actually
um
yeah correct so I I would just love to
see the cycle reset date a week after
the election
um would that interfere with somebody
uh continuing to raise money to settle
with that
well it it would however they're into
the next cycle so you could actually
make it they're they're paying their
debts for the election they just
finished so that's really that election
but it carries it forward and that's the
whole point like if the if their
organization is going to keep carrying
forward it actually gives them access to
the money faster to pay it off because
they can go back to so and so donor but
then they'd be raising money against the
limits for the next cycle but they have
debt they gotta get rid of their debts I
don't know I mean the debt stuff is not
used
the way I the way I've normally seen
debt use is it's to what to what their
point is which is a candidate will come
in they'll front load their election
um and they're just paying themselves
back it's not like I irosperity don't go
alone Jim qualey you know twenty
thousand dollars for your election or 10
whatever it is it's it's candidate debt
I've I've never seen in fact I've never
seen a debt that wasn't candidate debt
um because no no vendor will go on terms
with the candidate right or family death
correct family day yeah would it would
it
would the recycle date in terms of
accepting Contra say that uh six months
up to six months later you're still
raising money to uh apply to the the
2022 campaign not the 2024. yeah
yeah as long as it's transparent and
people know that you're doing that and
is reported as such
I I I I have a philosophical problem
with raising money for an election
that's already occurred I have a
philosophical problem with any limits on
Free Speech whatsoever
that's where my philosophical problem
kicks in is immediately but I guess I
don't have that same problem if you're
being transparent about it and you're
raising the money to pay off that that
you incurred and you just like the last
minute you did a huge mailing thing and
you're raising you've got people you
know out there you're paying yourself
off or however they're doing it as long
as you're transparent about it and it
was for that election so how long would
you have to do that
because I mean in theory I could do that
for an election and then two years later
be like yeah I'm paying off my 2022 debt
so give me uh the limit's 10K but you
can give me 20 because I'm going to send
that first 10K back to that mail and
it's already gone out
I don't know what what would be a
reasonable whatever reason I mean for me
the six months thing it seems to work or
you just do the end of the year I mean
part of me is it's a bit arbitrary but
it's entirely arbitrary I mean and then
you want to tie it into Wendy's the next
cycle begins so whenever that thing is
that date is that's the next cycle so so
I I I think I think you hit the nail on
the head so when does the next cycle
begin
whenever
I'm totally I'm totally on board with
everything you just said just when does
it begins is it Jan one because that
that makes some sense like you can make
that argument to me you can make you
know January one of the next odd year is
the beginning of a brand new cycle
um and that kind of keeps it in December
six months is a long time for me but you
know I'm not I'm not well I'm dying on
that if if the uh the concern is with
transparency
and the the contributions received and
applied towards a debt incurred in the
previous election that's all reported
and it's all
readily obtained by the public which
would be the case if we did go to
mandatory which would be more the case
if we went to
a requirement that reports be be
readable
right she already have that requirement
but it doesn't seem to be working too
well from the testimony we just heard
anyway if it's all transparent and
people can readily look it up then they
know the facts and they can make their
own judgments regarding what the
candidate's doing with the money and
where it came from I I guess the
situation I'm trying to avoid I'm sorry
not just on your point I I'm not sure I
think this might be a bit of a corner
case because you're imagining a campaign
that's carrying a debt that's going to
go try to raise money to pay off the
debt from the previous campaign while it
also might want to raise money for a
future campaign
and and the the people who would give
money to the past that and to the next
campaign are people who are a super
supportive because they have a lot of
and I have a lot of money but B didn't
max out in the previous campaign
and so you're super supportive super
wealthy contributors probably maxed out
in the previous campaign you can't raise
any money more money for them from the
past cycle anyway now so we're talking
about a very small number of potential
supporters who would be giving you money
after the election to retire debt right
up to the Limit and then give you money
again for the next cycle correct but
that's not how the money would work so
what would happen
this is the situation I'm trying to
avoid
let's say I'm running for governor God
forbid
yeah we agree yes
immediately the Pitchfork can sharpen
and immediately the Torches are lit well
it was just too easy and I take a
hundred thousand dollars of my money and
I shove it into my races alone and I
spend all 100 000 of that money right
and let's just say the contribution
limit per cycle is twenty thousand
dollars for a candidate whatever let's
stage 20 we're obviously Dr Tinker with
all this so let's say it's twenty
thousand dollars
so I go out and I spend my hundred grand
and I have this hundred thousand dollars
in debt and then God forbid I win my
election for governor right so I am now
I am now going to be in fact even under
some deadline I am now governor of the
state New Hampshire there's a really
scary thing
I can now go to you know John Doe super
donor who didn't support me in my race
for governor
and I can say yo uh give me 20 grand for
the last election and also give me 20
grand for the next election that's 40
Grand I'm gonna say it's going to debt
wink wink wink nudge nudge and the
reality is I'm just going to take that
20 grand on paper I'm going to pay
myself off and then roll it right back
into the next election so that a person
has effectively just given me 40 Grand
under the guise of paying off debt wink
wink nudge nudge because we unlike the
federal requirements in federal
requirements you're required to have
separate bank accounts and all sort of
stuff in under our laws have segregated
funds we don't actually Define what that
means it can literally be paper
segregated
um so it's it's all it's all just how
you're accounting for it and I guess
that's my that's my complaint for it is
like if you want to go to unlimited
contributions you got to go to unlimited
contributions like whatever many states
have that
um
but if we're gonna allow people to
donate to a campaign after the fact or
under the guys that they're paying off
debt and I just know from working in
that industry that that paying off of
debt is going to magically get rolled
because I'll tell you what will happen
I'd be like oh I just paid off twenty
thousand dollars of my campaign debt and
now I'm going to loan myself twenty
thousand dollars into the next year
conveniently and I wonder where the
money came from
but this would all be transparent
we would know who donated money when
yeah a a alleged you know it would be
transparent except for it's an
accounting trick you know I I if the
whole goal of this is to simplify this
and get it straightforward I I guess my
statement is we should limit the ability
to use accounting tricks and I know that
debt is an accounting trick I know that
the debt is an accounting trick for
these people because once they once
these campaign once these candidates put
their own money into the race I'm
telling you it is gone they have no
expectation it's actually coming back uh
and you could even make an argument to
me that they probably shouldn't be
getting it paid back because that looks
you want to talk about corruption that
actually looks even worse
realistic could they
they
if the date is January 1.
and they want to raise the money and
they go to the sky and say I want 20
000.
I mean part of it is do you you can't
start getting money for your new new
election until January 1 I don't know
you can roll the ballots for it right so
I mean once again it's an accounting
trick well the balance is it's a debt so
you're just going to roll the debt
forward and you're still going to have
the debt on paper and then you're going
to inject more debt on the other side
you know it's or raise more or raise
more yeah it's it's like it's an
accounting the debt is an accounting
trick if it's an accounting trip if the
objective is transparency by which I
think we mean
knowing who contributed
monies over certain threshold to a
candidate then we still are be able to
track that
pardon me for
continuing
there's there's still
uh
there's still a limit
for a given campaign again I'm kind of
violates my principles of Free Speech
but that's beside I understand the
notion of having to balance requirements
all right
so you still have a limit for the 2022
campaign
and we know who contributed money under
that limit
and we'll know the same for the 2024
campaign now you were talking about
what's the cutoff for contributing to a
2022 campaign well it seems reasonable
to me that reasonable what a word huh
but it seems reasonable to me that we
we try to structure a deadline that is
sufficiently in advance of the next
campaign that it's seems clear the
money's going to the previous campaign
January 1st of 2024 for example
at least amongst State amongst State
reps were working a much shorter
schedules than the bigger campaigns but
say after January 20 after January 1st
you can no longer contribute to the
previous even years campaign
that's a thought yeah no I I and I would
get over with that like but as long as
there's just a cut off date this that's
uniform it makes sense and doesn't allow
because I I kind of share that world
view it should be transparency but when
you try to play limits like I heard what
representative Meerhead said you know
but
I I just if if the goal here is to limit
the abilities to get around the law you
have to make it tight and you have to
make it consistent but you also to the
point you have to be able to pay off
debt like legitimate debt you have to be
paid off
um but I I guess I I do I I just want
the committee to be wary of the idea of
somebody wins elected office they're
carrying this debt and now they can go
to this person who did nothing for them
in 2022 and now that person who may have
an interest no I understand
we'll dip that money but there's a
there's a question of balancing things
on a slightly different topic by the way
related of course but uh
I do agree that there needs to be a
threshold below which individuals don't
individuals contributions don't have to
be identified by name because there's a
long tradition of
Anonymous public political speech right
The Federalist Papers were issued under
pseudonyms correct that's not the only
example that's just a general thought
yeah I I think I mean I spoke to this on
the first day
um I don't I I think getting things like
people's employers address is
arbitrary and
overly burdensome into to what end
um you know if you're somebody's
somebody's donating a ten thousand
dollars I think we all know who they
work for whether or not they put it on
their file or not that's not a that's
not just some walking around money you
know and uh
as a secretary of state Scanlon and Mr
Fitch pointed out it's a question of
how much money is likely to cause an
undue influence that's a judgment call
I thought that was an interesting
because how do you balance that I don't
know you said a number and we've got
right but do you do it by race because
you know 5000 is a lot to me I mean like
a lot I consider that real money yeah
yeah I consider a quarter real money
yeah exactly
but for the governor that's not
that's that's a drop in the bucket you
know so I I don't know whether we set
the same amount
for every race which I think is easier
to monitor
I mean but anyway I don't know but I
just thought it was insane
to that point I I think if the goal is
to streamline in this make a uniform it
should be uniform and there is a you
know five thousand dollars to Governor
may not be allowed but five thousand
dollars to a state rep as a whole like
that's a lot that's a lot of money
um
a thousand lots of money but I do think
whatever we set that number at I think
it actually should be the same across
the board across all of it
um because the reality is if somebody's
raising whatever the number is
you know I wouldn't set it at five
thousand that's too hot that's too
that's not low enough right
um that's too high another impression I
was left with is that
there's
a considerable amount of low-hanging
fruit that we could pluck to improve
things in terms of
the laws being consistent
in less subject to misinterpretation the
example that uh representative Elena
representative Lane and I have in common
with the current online campaign Finance
system
I still don't know exactly what the
right answer was
in fact when I when I hit submit
yesterday
I got a message that said this uh sorry
this transaction cannot be processed and
yet when I looked at the list of reports
I had filed
the report I had just attempted to file
was there yeah so that's why I said
earlier I made a very I made a I put a
fair bit of time into trying to do this
right and made a good faith effort to
get it right and I believe my
information is now publicly accessible
but there's glitches like that that
right you run across the same thing yeah
same thing so not just make good
because I did I thought what they told
me to do and then it showed up that I
actually had 500 instead of five because
they said what's the amount of the
excess and it was 500 and something and
so I put that in and then what it did is
it showed that as being raised
right so it looks like
it it it's not right but I don't know
how to fix it I experimented some with
that I think I got an answer that's
correct when I asked in that portion of
the site to put in the amount you're
you're carrying forward it's the amount
that you carried forward into the 2022
campaign not the amount you're carrying
forward from because when when I did
that their numbers agreed with my own
spreadsheet okay I think I'll be
amending mine yeah try try that
I had the same sounds like we had
exactly the same very similar situation
to that point when we one of the things
that I do think we should discuss is I I
think we're going to be able to get on
board collectively yes on the
streamlining on the simplification on
the universal dates
um I think we're going to get there
um one of the things that I I think we
should consider is some form of either
amnesty or forgiveness period or let's
call it reconciliation into the new
laws so that people whose math doesn't
add up or they're confused or whatever
can just say I've got
twelve hundred dollars in my account
it's from these other campaigns you know
I'm and we're all moving forward now
it's just something that if you want to
bring as many people out of the shadows
as possible I think you have to do
something like that
um and just have to move on and then and
then from that point the second the
Attorney General's office can then take
more robust enforcement because you've
gotten the massive Come Out of The
Shadow period if you will oh wow former
member of election law joining us today
greetings
um but anyways I just think it's
something to say it's going to be
something that I'm sure somebody is
going to Tweet nasty things about it but
I think if the goal is to open up
transparency streamline things you need
to bring as many people
into the fold as possible and give them
every incentive to do so and then after
that you can highly disincentivize them
coming out of the fault
with your 50 day fines that they send
out those letters that I definitely
didn't receive
yeah yeah I don't know what you're
talking about it's gonna
wholesale rewriting of this whole
chapter yeah I agree it's it's going to
be a whole I mean look it's okay you
know it's going to be a what
wholesale rewriting of this chapter
yeah yeah it well it has to be yeah
otherwise what are we doing we're just
gonna sit here and fight over the
numbers and right like I I really I love
you guys I just don't want to waste you
know six hours of my life here
well I don't find your presence to be
away so let me reassure you if we don't
do anything it's definitely a waste
right correct no
well I
I think of it as trying to put it puts
the laws through a clarifying filter if
we just make them more consistent and
right and ease and uh
simple to comply with while still
achieving the basic objective of
transparency okay that seems to be the
that's what I'm getting out of this
that's kind of our objective I think
I'm sure we can do it
so I I expect we can find something
we can actually find that we can all
agree on oh I I do too I just think when
the devil's always in the details when
you start writing it I think
conceptually we can it's but so do do we
want to start
tackling that do we wait I think we
should start tackling because we're not
going to get anything past right I mean
now we're just we're doing a report
right we don't even know we don't we're
a subcommittee we don't right we're not
handling a piece of legislation so I
mean we can we can take as long as we
could take as long as we want I I my
goal with this and in agreeing to do
this was that we would come to a
consensus on something and that the
committee as a whole would then
co-sponsor legislation in the next
filing period okay some of that all six
of us can get on board with to show
strength and unity of that and I'm sure
that there will be ideas outside of that
and they will be handled outside of that
um but then we can power something
forward that's actually that we can say
Republicans and Democrats are on board
in this historically partisan committee
but we all agree on this and we can pass
it forward and that gives us the best
opportunity to
to send it through to our friends on the
other side of the wall who will then do
God knows well with it well from my
perspective the first step would be to
uh
write out something that's that's
doesn't have to be long but just
spelling out what requirements we think
the campaign finds Finance system has to
to meet for example establish
transparency in the campaign fine the
flow of campaign money
uh
that's one requirement but there's going
to be subsidiary requirements because
there's other things we need to respect
I think we need to respect the ability
of people who are not contributing
amounts of money that could be construed
as having undue influence on a candidate
I think that we need to protect their
ability to
uh donate anonymously especially in in a
political environment that can become
very polarized and contentious
we don't want people to have to worry
that they're if it's a modest amount of
money we don't have to we don't want
them worrying about blowback
from
you understand what I'm saying by that
yeah we don't want to discourage people
from contributing to candidates because
every last penny is subject to attack
from somebody that they've never met
does that make sense right is that but I
guess I would want that to be a minimal
amount well that's that's where
discussion comes in well there's
something like that
there is it's it's uh
we raised it from 25 to 50 last uh the
last biennium and then it's anything
over 200 that's when the employer
information kicks in right but I'm
saying we need to preserve that and what
that exact level is we have to discuss
but that but that's like a requirement
that we have a protection in there
uh you know I I agree and I I would make
the armor that 50 is too low
and and that's part of the discussion
but there needs to be a limit below
which someone can make a donation to a
candidate and the fact that that
candidate received the money from
somebody
is is this is a reasonable requirement
okay so I'm just giving an example of no
you got a donation of 50 say you you
record that and report it
uh I'm just giving an example it's not
just transparency there are other
requirements we also have to meet I'll
be thinking about that myself and that
might be something good to spend a
little time on at our next meeting to
see if we have how much overlap we have
between what we see the requirements
being that next meeting will be next
Tuesday by the way and
that that doesn't need to be the last
meeting we could meet again it's not
going to be a short-term effort no this
no
right the wholesale rewrite I took it as
published on the State website the the
portion of 664.
all I did was a little formatting so I
could read it easier but this is it here
it's uh
probably oh yeah about 20 pages
single spaced that's the cam pain
Finance stuff so it's not going to be a
short-term effort to run through that
and get it internally consistent while
still meeting the requirements which I
think we should Define first
okay I have to ask is this making sense
to people
so for our next meeting
we should I it would be a good idea I
think to at least have some preliminary
ideas on what the requirements would be
and
uh is anyone here averse to having
future meetings
maybe monthly
we just need to make sure we time it
that we're meeting frequently enough to
get the work done inside of the filing
window
because I I imagine we'll have but we're
going to try to it's uh November right I
don't I couldn't I should know it's
later in the year
yeah yeah and then but the State House
is also closed at a certain point
um that doesn't mean we can't meet at
another location you just have to go get
speakers blessing and he's
last time I did that I got a little bit
of pushback but
anyway we can discuss that further yeah
[Music]
yeah that's when you want to have all
the Minions right I think we should only
meet in September
all right
all right okay so yeah I know I think we
need to meet once a month may not be I
mean that might be a big yeah I'm not
being I'm not being I'm just yeah this
is just kind of I guess the main thought
I have here really is that
uh if we're actually going to make any
progress it doesn't seem like we can do
anything
with only one more meeting
that's my main point scheduling I'm not
talking about here but it looks like
we'll have to have a few more meetings
I I think at our next meeting one of the
things that I think we could easily do
is come to a consensus on what the
reporting date should be and it sounds
like nobody really get pushback to
making those reporting dates uniform
across the board for all various
organizations
so I think people should come to the
next one with an idea of what what you
think that should look like
um and then we can
that's it
yeah okay that makes sense I still think
we need to have a good you know my
experience was as a systems engineer
where you start with requirements and
you flow it down it's a and when you're
dealing with a complicated system and
that's what this is
that is a good approach but it doesn't
mean we can't do some of the details we
think we already understand that would
apply so that's an example
I'm almost tempted to do a control a
delete but yeah
the control I'll delete control they
delete and start again it's just so
nasty but yeah
[Music]
um
confused so because every time you
change something it's like right yeah
there's the ripple effect which is why
which is why something like
a fresh start should not entirely be off
out of cons out of
out of discussion but it would also be
satisfying to make some short-term
progress as well to encourage us
like for example come up with a uniform
set of reporting dates
yeah well I I think what we should do is
we should come up with a uniform set of
principles
general concepts that we can all agree
upon well that's the that's the
requirements I was talking about I think
and then so General General set of
principles we all agree upon and then
build almost just build from there
what that looks like and we have our
current RSA that we can look at for
reference and
and make sure that things that don't
fall through the cracks but that's
honestly when you're touching something
that complicated is this and as dense as
this
you really to representative Lane's
point it's really hard to go and touch
something that doesn't ripple effect and
then set off a bunch of firestorms it
may actually be easier just to pull it
out put a new engine under the hood
yes well yeah and as I was saying we're
going to do that with one more meeting
no so we can just we can discuss when
the next meeting should be
next week
I just want to clarify something in my
mind that
that's going to be
it's going to include
does that include all these independent
expenditures
groups that don't coordinate with
campaign I mean I just want to figure
out because I think a lot of this gets
complicated because they were addressing
different kinds of entities as they kind
of came in to existence so I'm just
trying to figure out
when we go through and get that when you
the three areas Pacs committees and
candidates what distinguishes a pack
from a committee a Pac party packs
parties and commit and candidates oh Pax
parties yeah
and I think one of the things to look at
is how the feds handled the McCain final
transition
because they moved from basically the
world of kind of Lawless Federal
elections into a highly structured right
thing so it's kind of I I do want to I
mean I'll ask Christina take a look at
how the feds handled that transition
okay because I yeah I started looking at
the the FED stuff a little bit just to
try and figure out
you know so but for us then it's going
to be the term political committee or
whether we call it political action
committee or whatever is going to be all
different kinds of committees
I don't I don't know I haven't really
thought that through I think my goal
would be to make one overarching
political action committee pack whatever
you want to call political committee
whatever name we give it right the not
party not candidate political arm okay
right and make it have Universal rules
Universal contribution limits and
Universal guiding things of what they
can do they cannot coordinate with
candidates and political parties right
so they can't coordinate they're their
own separate entity that's that's you
know Barry and Lane getting together two
people getting a thousand dollars and
starting to spend money on people which
would be interesting but
um that that would be my idealistic view
we would get to that world which is why
I asked the question about you know how
do we handle things like citizens united
with
you know soup like super pact and that
sort of thing because I think one of the
things that
um attorney Fitch was off on is the
citizens united did create a Gateway for
unlimited spending
um and we I'm sure we have philosophical
disagreements on that but it's a reality
that we have to and that's why I asked
that question is how do we how do I how
do we create one definition for a
political committee that also abides by
that but doesn't just go into like
something that people who want to see
the restraint
can be satisfied as well
he said don't don't he he was highly
advising uh representative Elaine to uh
to uh yeah don't ruin my week maybe have
a glass of wine beforehand
because I I think
I think it was relied on on transparency
and on disclosure as you know you can
you can have Free Speech but you have to
know who's giving the speech is kind of
how I've always thought of it as so but
they've so I don't know about unlimited
I still it kind of freaks me we we will
we will solve that not today but that's
yeah that was that was the point of my
question was how do you
how do you have one definition that
balances that without right okay without
having nine different definitions of
pack which is what we have now all right
there there are
things to create or problems to solve
that can take
a lot of discussion before okay can can
arrive at a mutually agreeable
uh solution for lack of a better word
okay all right uh then are we all
satisfied to adjourn this meeting
then the meeting is adjourned
thank you very much and thank you
esteemed members of the public for being
here and being interested thank you
foreign